let's bring in Tom Curren who joins us
obviously from somebody else's house
the Patriots insider from NBC Sports
Boston because he's got awards in the
background what are those what are those
gold things he got back there they are
expensive they were on sale and I was
able to pick up a pair of them so yeah
appreciate you noticing well I can't
help but notice it it's right over your
shoulder with your sports Emmys I'm
missing it let's see he's got the same
going on I do I don't know who earned I
don't know if either one of you earned
those sports Emmys but Paulie I'm
missing two sports Emmys this makes
sense you might be missing for now hmm
all right Tommy
hashtag Tommy you do not like the
possibility of Andy Dalton coming in to
save the day for the Patriots why is he
not a good fit in New England he's just
a souped up Brian Hoyer it's not that
he's a good fit or a bad fit it's just
the same thing as Brian Hoyer in the
Patriots right now are a team that if
you ask me they are best-case scenario
ten and six most likely about eight Nate
and if things don't go well six and ten
so what difference does Andy Dalton make
it's not gonna get you to the divisional
playoff he's not gonna get you to Tampa
Bay in the Super Bowl so just take your
medicine find out what you have in Jared
Stidham you're up against the cap leave
it alone and then go on with 20/20 and
see what 2021 breaks I don't know Bill
Belichick I've I think I've spoken to
him and said four words to him and that
was when he won the Super Bowl but when
it comes to his ego of trying to prove
he could win with Jared Stidham as
opposed to Tom Bray how like how
important is that element to Bill
Belichick I don't think it's as opposed
to winning with Brady but I do think
that there is an element throughout the
Patriots that says look we know what
we're doing here we understand how to
win football games and Brady is
unbelievable and he did great things for
us for a long time but let's be honest
there's a lot of things that he could
have done better too and there's other
guys who can do somewhat similar things
and that that's the thing when you think
about it in you get a sixth round pick
one six Super Bowls
for the last 20 years when they had to
go to a backup it was a seventh round
pick we didn't play college football at
USC Brian Hoyer has been in the league
for eleven years now he was undrafted
Garoppolo was a division 2 pick that's
why all this to a talk and just a
Herbert and tank for Trevor it doesn't
make sense the Patriots aren't built for
diva quarterbacks why maybe until you
mean bills personality won't allow it
just what Brady grew and grew and grew
and he was entitled to do so but to talk
about Cam Newton as so many people have
as a possibility well he doesn't want
someone who's feels they might be bigger
than the program or as big as a program
or program unto themselves he just got
out from under that we're gonna look at
this now with the Aaron Rodgers
speculation his Belichick gonna want to
sign up for Rodgers he just got off that
train no why didn't the Patriots draft a
quarterback stood him I think they felt
comfortable with Stidham they were in
the market and I'd be curious to know
whether or not they were looking at
jaylen Hertz who i viously went to
Philadelphia but they were looking but
in the final analysis Stidham is a
player who would have been a first-round
talent had he been in this year's draft
and you knew about him now what you knew
about him from the last year he turned
into a depressed asset at Auburn in his
last year and then Dan Patriots took him
he played well there's nothing that he
did that made you say wow we gotta go
get a new guy to compete with him who
just came out of college do you think
there's more confidence in Stidham then
there was Garoppolo when they first got
Garoppolo similar I think it's I think
it's identical
what hurts Stidham though Dan is going
into this second year with no
preparation you look at the to 2010 2011
draft classes those lockout years those
players who came in at the quarterback
position the best one among the group
was Cam Newton's second best Colin
Kaepernick other than that it's Blaine
Gabbert Jake Locker Christian Ponder and
a collection of not very good if I told
you two months ago Brady's gonna be in
Tampa and Gronk is gonna be with him
you would have said one I would have
said Kronk is too skinny and he
definitely isn't coming back
seriously croc I would have believed the
Brady part I absolutely would have
believed the Brady part the Gronkowski
part caught me completely flat-footed I
did not see it happening and really I
wrote this last week he really
outflanked Belichick and kind of
Belichick Belichick on this it was no
recourse yeah you're right because they
couldn't pay for him and Gronk's
basically saying hey I want to come back
alright but I know you can't take me
back because I'm too expensive oh I
guess I'll go to the Buccaneers can you
send me to the Buccaneers but I won't go
anyplace else but and the beautiful
thing like he could have really been a
dink instead I'm coming back and they
said we're not gonna trade you okay
well too bad I'm under contract you're
gonna have to either cut me or to start
cutting guys if they start cutting guys
three weeks down the road he could say
change my mind but do you believe that
Gronk had the playbook of the Buccaneers
for the last month I don't believe he
had it for the last month I believe that
he probably has had conversations with
Brady as to here's some of the things
that we can definitely be doing if you
sign I can't imagine that they wouldn't
be on the phone he said I'm coming to
Tampa okay
what are we gonna do can't tell you yet
no it's not gonna work
no it's like Yelp you go on Yelp and you
check the menu of the restaurant you're
gonna go to I'm sure that this was his
way of going on Yelp Brady gave him the
playbook and said hey yeah and then so
Gronk's had it for a while it's just
drunk being Gronk tells everybody that
he's had to play book for a month is
this a big deal if you're the NFL and
and Brady's involved in this like it I
in and you know these times it feels
like a small story becomes a bigger
story because the media has nothing else
to talk about right is this a big deal
if you're the Commissioner of the NFL
that Gronk may have had this playbook
while under contract with New England
Patriots I don't think so just because
he hadn't been active last year I mean
if you want to chase it to the ends of
the earth you probably can make a case
for saying hey don't do that again I
don't know if you're gonna find him or
take a draft
dick I mean you're not it wasn't Bruce
Arians it wasn't Jason light its Brady
yeah it's player two player contact in
conversation I mean if we're gonna get
to that point with tampering where
players can't talk to their colleagues I
it's well sending guys sending the
playbook that was a little different
well I know just a little don't be an
apologist there I don't want to talk
about it okay
could you imagine if they did a last
dance on the Patriots this past year oh
we would start in twenty it would start
right after the 2016 Superbowl right
after the comeback against Atlanta
that's when it would begin because
that's when it started that's when Brady
was of a mind that look I got my fifth
that's not something a Bradshaw did
that's not something that Montana did
I'm on a different plane now and he was
in that offseason convinced to start
doing things differently you saw Tom
versus time you saw a greater an effort
to get the tv12 stuff out there and
that's where he and Belichick clashed
and grew apart
going into 2017 and he wanted Garoppolo
replaced or at least surety about his
own situation and Belichick resisted and
Kraft resisted it so yeah it's it's as
fascinating as the Jordan stuff I think
but if I and I've asked you this before
I'll ask it again if you could find out
the real reason why Garoppolo was traded
who was involved in it who orchestrated
it or why Malcolm Butler was benched
after one or two plays in the Super Bowl
which one would you want to know Oh
Butler
completely I can tell you like a Rapala
was traded I know why it was traded they
had no recourse he wasn't taking any
invitations to stay with the team
Belichick knew it Belichick meant they
never made an offer to him contractually
to stay but you don't think did
Belichick looked at him as the future
yeah he did until Brady blew it up well
okay so yeah so Brady is the one who
said you got to get rid of him and and
Belichick didn't want that
well Belichick didn't like that but
Belichick knew he had to do that I mean
Brady would have been Brady through 28
touchdown passes and two picks in 2016 -
four games so he would have been the MVP
you just want to sue
well he was the MVP of 2017 at threw for
505 he's the best player in football
they were not keeping Jimmy Garoppolo
Belichick had no intention of it
Belichick understood Brady was better
see this is what has gotten traction and
lived is the Kraft push Belichick they
never tried to keep Garoppolo they
wanted to but they never made an
official offer yeah but that always
leads me to that's all you got for Jimmy
Garoppolo look at what these
quarterbacks get an unproven guy a draft
pick you know Jared Goff and Carson
Wentz look at what got king's ransom for
these guys and you got what for Jimmy
Garoppolo how many games did Jimmy
Garoppolo have left under contract when
he got sent to San Francisco
I don't okay eight you were only getting
eight games out of me sent a
second-round pick you I don't promise
that he was gonna stick with you
you could have franchised him that was
gonna cost 25 million I mean you're
right but the Devils in the details here
this is less conspiratorial than the
Malcolm Butler thing yeah we'll never
get that and I there's part of me that
applauds Belichick for for not allowing
that out of the the building I'd love to
know but I you know if if I'm a player
who's going there are they gonna keep my
secrets there and I I would have I
appreciate Belichick not you know
gossiping you know what and I think the
butler did too because Butler took a
million bullets so whatever Butler did
yeah and I think he did something the
fact that he took the onus on himself
and said look I was sick early in the
week and my head wasn't in the game and
I understand he didn't understand he
just knew that he had done something
during the week whether it was
insubordination or worse that was gonna
make it look bad for him if he got the
free agency and every team knew that he
got himself benched for the Super Bowl
by being a dick I personally think that
Belichick you know took a ak-47 to a
mosquito with that issue and should have
backed off it but that's that's that's
enough I'll leave you with this
well the Patriots make the soup make the
plows no mmm
okay no
what are you gonna do in January I'm
gonna wind I'm gonna go pick up some
more energy you're gonna pick them up
from my studio and bring me in your
house hey great to talk to you thanks
for joining us we appreciate it thank
you that's Tom Curren covers the patriot